il mio lavoro e correggere i ricordi lo
faccio spesso per me la sera prima di
andare a dormire ma volte lo faccio
anche per altri come in questa storia
che sto per raccontarvi questa è una
storia dimenticata una storia d'altri
tempi
una storia bellissima tutt'altro che
leggendaria è una storia molto attuale
per le cose che racconta
ecco io oggi sento l'esigenza di
raccontare le grandi donne della scienza
non soltanto perché io sono una fisica
non soltanto perché sono una donna ma
perché non sono più una musa ispiratrice
per qualcun altro non sono una
principessa che cerca la scarpetta che
ha perso
sono storie ormai del passato queste lo
fanno più parte del nostro mondo
il sento l'esigenza di fare questi
racconti e soprattutto per la nostra
società per quello che vediamo fuori per
quello che ci raccontano i giornali che
abbiamo sotto gli occhi tutti i giorni
quando accendiamo la televisione i
bambini l'hanno già capito
i bambini hanno fatto un sondaggio hanno
fatto un sondaggio e hanno chiesto qual
è il personaggio preferito nella storia
nella saga di harry potter
tutti hanno risposto hermione hermione
la mia ragazza a secchiona quella che si
dà da fare e che ha le sue cose perché
se li è guadagnati ma non reporter che
un maghetto miracolato con i poteri che
gli sono caduti dall'alto no secchiona
essere secchione oggi una cosa fila non
è più come come venivano viste nel
passato
ecco questo racconto che voglio farvi
oggi questa storia parte da molto
lontano
è il racconto di una donna straordinaria
che non è stata un'annata abbastanza ma
da cui noi oggi possiamo trarre tutte le
energie per per realizzare i nostri
sogni perché noi oggi possiamo fare
tutto quello che vogliamo lo sapete no
tutto non è più come nel ventesimo
secolo
ecco questa è la storia tutt'altro che
leggendaria di lise meitner quando olive
meitner è nata
vienna nella ricca vienna nella vienna
borghese è nata da una famiglia borghese
ebrea werner heisenberg aveva quanto
werner heisenberg è nato lise meitner
aveva già 23 anni è werner heisenberg è
nato il 5 dicembre del 1901 lise meitner
sera appena diplomata all'accademia ken
gymnasium vien e per le donne
l'insegnamento doveva finire già alle
medie
però lei viveva in una casa molto ricca
con questi genitori che le davano tutte
le dava la possibilità di studiare anche
privatamente e dunque lei ha voluto
proseguire gli studi ha voluto
proseguire gli studi ma non si è fermata
lì perché la sua curiosità era
spropositata
ecco un giorno passeggiando con la marra
madre faceva muovere lise in una casa
enorme candelabri d'argento tappeti dal
valore inestimabile pianoforti a coda
mali se tutto quello non le interessava
camminando con liz e la madre stava
attenta a non schivare le pozzanghere va
appena piovuto
se invece c'entrava dentro con i piedi
si insaccava voleva proprio vedere cosa
succedeva quando quando trovava delle
pozzanghere in particolare si è chinata
una volta che ha visto la luce che
veniva riflessa in una maniera diversa a
seconda dell'angolazione la madre perché
si era sporcata una scenata chi voleva
capire qualcosa di più e ha iniziato a
fare nuove domande ma non sono certo i
genitori e maestre a darti quelle
risposte
e così ha iniziato a fare le sue
ricerche sui libri fortunatamente quella
casa era piena di libri e voleva voleva
trovare le sue risposte alle grandi
domande guardando fuori perché
l'arcobaleno sempre quei colori il rosso
arancione giallo verde blu sempre in
quell'ordine perché sto dietro un vetro
quando c'è il sole
non mi abbronza se sto davanti invece
mia bronzo
ecco lì sei meitner trovava quelle
risposte cercando nei libri di scienza
in particolare si si interessa una
disciplina che nessuno le racconta
nessuno le spiega che cos'è la madre
figuriamoci la disciplina era la fisica
la fisica
nessuno ti dice bene che cosa
rappresenti per lui
elisa no man mano possiamo costruire un
piano inclinato nel giardino per
dimostrare che galileo aveva ragione da
abbiamo già una fontana lo sai che la
fontana non si adatta niente allora lì
se smette di fare queste richieste alla
madre la elimina
e inizia il 10 a frequentare i grandi
professori perché chiede di fare delle
elezioni delle lezioni private per chi
vuole iscriversi all'università di
vienna
non ci sono donne l'università di alla
facoltà di fisica la madrina di motivava
in tutte le maniere mortai come tua
sorella caro ha trovati un bel ragazzo
da queste scemenze qui dicono i genitori
a un certo punto lise si incaponisce si
chiude nella stanza apposta perché vuole
perché vuole concentrarsi e vuole
passare questo esame di ammissione
difficilissimo e ce la fa giorno della
consegna della tesina e poi risultati
lise meitner ammessa sarà l'unica donna
presente a quel corso a 350 ragazzi
quale non le importava voleva studiare
fisica era quello suo sogno è dunque
prosegue prosegue nel suo percorso e lei
fa così non gli sono sufficienti alle
elezioni e quando vedeva che c'era un
professore che teneva un convegno allora
si scriveva il convegno lo seguiva e poi
lo andava a trovare nello studio per
approfondire gli argomenti da loro che
si possono avere risposte e dunque vede
che un giorno doveva tenere questo
conferenza il grande lou trimble routine
volta era fantastico lo immaginava
l'atomo
a quei tempi l'atomo non era possibile
immaginarlo
non si sapeva come era fatto figuriamoci
nel ventesimo secolo xix aiuto che un po
c'è voluta la fisica quantistica per
capire il mondo dell'infinitamente
piccolo allora lise segue la conferenza
di questo tipo un po tutto scapigliato
ma nel suo studio e propone già leggera
già oltre va già letto tutto quello che
lui aveva scritto egli aveva detto ma
immaginiamo di bombardare degli atomi
con una radiazione arfa che diamo cosa
succede
certo dice woods non certo lo fa crea un
esperimento e poi pubblica un articolo
balls man sull'emissione dei raggi alfa
da parte dei metalli capito va avanti va
avanti il percorso di lise esegue questa
conferenza di questo ottoman si chiamava
così quasi la sua età aveva
interessantissimo ma venne fatto da lui
va nel suo ufficio
egli propone dei nuovi esperimenti da
fare blanc a quando li vede parlare
insieme non ci crede erano la coppia
perfetta farà in modo che lei venga
presa come come lavorante all'interno
del laboratorio ecco diciamo così
lavorante vabbè le donne di quei tempi
non potevano essere pagate dovevano
autofinanziarsi il lavoro se volevano
lavorare in un laboratorio di fisica
per non parlare del fatto che le donne
dovevano entrare sul retro tutti passano
dall ingresso principale lise mai tanto
da fare il giro ed entrare dall'ingresso
secondario
queste sono le regole del ventesimo
secolo ma lisa non gliene fregava stava
realizzando i suoi sogni era questa la
cosa bella per lei un importante niente
i due iniziano pubblicare articoli
pubblicati su le donne possono soltanto
mettere la sigla non possono mettere il
loro nome per esteso è dunque iniziano a
pubblicare articolo 1908 aprile
sull'assorbimento dei raggi alfa e beta
da parte dei metalli giugno 1908 sulle
emissioni di raggi beta dell'attilio
settembre 1908 il rinculo radioattivo la
madre quando sente di questo rinculo
radiati o melis che ci ha insegnato a
parlare
bene va avanti va avanti pubblicano
articoli entrambi siglando tutto quello
che loro scrivono o punto h punto l
punto m punto quello che pubblicano
arriva alle orecchie di un certo rutter
ford ai più grandi e mi chiama lirici
voglio conoscere questo punto h punto l
punto m.ma sono molto interessanti le
cose che dicono e voglio capirci un
attimo meglio voglio discutere con loro
di fisica di far arrivare in inghilterra
e li vede arrivare no
volete arrivare dal fondo un corridoio
così si avvicinano piano piano sistema
meglio gli occhiali 11 aiat è avanti 8 a
certo mm una donna che lei era una donna
guardi signorina qui fuori c'è mia
moglie andate a fare compere mentre io
il dottor en parliamo di fisica così
dice frater ford
ecco einstein definiva questi paludati
accademici einstein dirà è inutile che
gli spiegate come il mondo sta andando
adesso gli influssi che arrivano
benefici dalle arti dalla musica dai
film voi se non lo capisco ma non è
importante
tra poco moriranno diceva questo va
avanti elisa infatti se ne frega
figuriamoci einstein e ha iniziato a
definirla lei conosce tutti in quel
periodo perché i suoi lavori erano
strepitosi e chi se ne fregava del fatto
più la donna ma soltanto per meriti la
omaggiava era albert einstein era marie
curie
ansa la definisce la nostra marie curie
la marie curie tedesca e poi un certo
werner heisenberg un giovane scalpitante
tedesco inizia a guardarla inizia a
essere completamente sedotto dalla sua
intelligenza così fanno con lisa mi
piace come ragione mi piace come parla
ci sono delle donne che diventano brutte
appena aprono bocca
altri invece che affascinano più parlano
e più diventano belle che semmai
tollererà questo inizia incuriosirsi
in quel periodo lì stava nascendo un
gran gruppo di lavoro è in europa stava
nascendo il gruppo che avrebbe dato le
basi alla fisica quantistica niels bohr
da copenaghen
era il grande e orchestratore era il
grande maestro che teneva tutti
all'interno della dei suoi del suo
edificio heisenberg era l'allievo più
scalpitante creerà al suo principio di
indeterminazione di heisenberg che pone
le basi sulla teoria ortodosso della
fisica quantistica lise meitner proprio
sul mondo dell'infinitamente piccolo era
ormai un'esperta tiziana candidarla per
la vittoria del premio nobel insieme
otto hahn una volta niente due volte
sostenuta a gran voce da niels bohr da
insegna a marie curie da heisenberg due
volte niente terza volta niente quarta
volta niente 10 non riesce mai a
vincerlo
la coppia 8 anne lise meitner verrà
candidata dieci volte non lo vincerà mai
1933 sale al potere adolf hitler viene
diffusa la legge secondo cui tutti i
professori gli studenti di origine
ebraica dovevano abbandonare le scuole
lise meitner ebrea va su ball nord prima
passa da copenhagen al mix bohr e poi va
in svezia
einstein partirai andrà in america
andranno via tutti matt berninger
germania per dire ai suoi talenti
migliori rimarranno lì heisenberg 8 en
blanc a lavorare dentro lise meitner in
svezia
da lì continua a lavorare con 8 a a
distanza attuale continuerà a fare i
suoi esperimenti di laboratorio e si
scambieranno lettere aprile 1938 8 anna
scrive alise è successa una cosa strana
oggi durante un esperimento è avvenuto
come uno scoppio non riesco a
spiegarmelo
va bene va bene dice lì se dobbiamo
incontrarci devo capire qualcosa di più
di questo scoppio e dunque fa in modo di
incontrarsi con
con con otto hahn di nascosto da tutti
proprio a copenaghen da niels bohr che
li ospita la danimarca sarà terra
occupata dal 41 e dunque riusciranno
incontrarsi a parlare parlano un'ora due
ore tre ore quattro ore poi 8 amelie da
un blocco di fogli gli dice queste sono
tutte le cose che ho trovato nel mio
esperimento dai un occhio per favore
cerca di risalire a quello che è
avvenuto a questo scopo
va bene lisa se lo porta a casa in
svezia settembre 1938 lise meitner
scrive a otto hahn neutroni ad alta
energia questi miei calcoli
seguono dieci pagine di calcoli
raffinatissimi in cui racconta tutto
quello che è avvenuto in quel
laboratorio verrà attribuito il premio
nobel per la chimica a 8
in questa cerimonia per il ritiro del
nobel otto anni non nomina mai lise
meitner va bene mi interessa lise
meitner pensava al nobel che fosse una
di quelle statuette di soprammobili che
la madre teneva in casa non gliene
fregava niente voleva continuare a fare
fisica la fisica quella bella e dunque
continuerà a farlo in svezia e poi andrà
a cambridge a cambridge e proseguirà
quando sentirà della notizia della bomba
delle bombe sul giappone da parte degli
americani entrerà in un momento di
depressione che non ha eguali vivrà il
periodo più brutto della sua vita
porterà avanti campagne per il disarmo
per la pace cercherà di portare avanti a
più non posso tutte le i negoziati per
la costruzione dell'agenzia atomica
delle nazioni unite dedicherà la sua
vita per la pace e contro la creazione
di armi
l'ism ai primi morirà a 90 anni a
cambridge sulla sua tomba
c'è un epitaffio giornata vederla lise
meitner una fisica che non ha perso mai
la sua umanità ma il mio lavoro e
correggere i ricordi lo faccio spesso
per me la sera prima di andare a dormire
in questa storia lo faccio anche per
altri
in questo caso lise meitner nell'ultimo
periodo della sua vita
ha approfondito un aspetto che che forse
per noi è la cosa più attuale più utile
per la nostra vita di tutti i giorni ha
cercato di capire quanto sono imparo
importante le cose che diciamo quanto
sono importanti le persone che
avviciniamo e quelle conquistiamo
insieme in una delle ultime lettere che
ha scritto prima di morire dall'ospedale
c'è pure quella indirizzata a werner
heisenberg gli disse una frase
bellissima gli disse con le parole siamo
complici forse dovrebbe essere questo
l'epitaffio reale su quella tomba equa
lise meitner ha avuto la capacità di
farci capire a tutti noi di non stare
con chi non ci fa fiorire lei come le
altre grandi donne della scienza portano
avanti questi valori questi principi è
per me sono fondamentali
riuscire ad entrare nella loro vita per
capire la mia l'ism a jean marie curie
rosalind franklin rita margherita
samantha fabiola da c'è barbara
mcclintock tutte donne straordinarie che
hanno creato nuove città dove vivere
nuove porti dove realizzarci mi viene in
mente pienamente calvino per questi
porti non saprei tracciare la rotta su
una carta né fissare la data di un
approdo alle volte basta uno scorcio che
s'apre nel bel mezzo di un paesaggio
incontro un affiorare di luci nella
nebbia
il dialogo tra due passanti che si
incontrano nel viavai per pensare che
partendo di li metterò assieme pezzo a
pezzo la città perfetta fatta di
frammenti che si mescolano con il resto
fatta distanti separati da intervalli
fatta di segnali che uno manda e non sa
chi li raccoglie
se ti dico che la città verso cui tende
il mio viaggio e discontinua nello
spazio nel tempo
tu non puoi credere che si può smettere
di cercarla l'inferno dei viventi non è
qualcosa che sarà se ce n'è uno e gia
qui è quello che viviamo tutti i giorni
stando insieme due modi ci sono per non
soffrirne il primo
e facile a molti adattarsi all'inferno e
farne parte
fino al punto da non vederlo più il
secondo è rischioso ed esige attenzione
e apprendimento continui cercare e saper
riconoscere chi e cosa in mezzo
all'inferno non è inferno e farlo durare
e dargli spazio lise meitner rosalind
franklin rita margherita samantha
fabiola da chen tutte queste donne
riunite in un'unica equazione saranno
una la continuazione dall'altra e
saremmo una il testimone dell'alta io
prenderò il testimone da loro e lo
porterò in giro e specchiando mi in
queste donne vedo riflessa alla parte di
me stessa di prendermi cura come il più
prezioso dei regali della vita
[Applauso]